all right thank you hi this is my first
time in front of many of you so I
figured I would give you kind of one
slide of introduction I don't want to go
too far into what I'm doing because I
know many of you will be here tomorrow
and I'm talking a little bit more
broadly about research there but my
research is in empirical security and
privacy a lot of looking at the real
world events that are taking place on
the Internet today there's kind of in
three major themes of this one has been
building systems to actually collect
data about what's going on on the
internet a lot of this has been involved
in internet wide scanning understanding
how web servers mail servers have been
deployed but it's all spent a lot of
working with industry groups to
understand what they see in their data
working with groups like Google and
Amazon and CloudFlare to look at the
incoming connections notice I understand
what is going on on the internet it's
massively distributed but oftentimes we
need this kind of global perspective in
order to make the right policy decisions
in order to understand errors that have
been made in deployment and in order to
understand how to build kind of the next
generation of protocols and how they'll
fit in with what's already out there but
actually today I wanted to actually talk
about an event that kind of I think sets
the stage a little bit for today and
kind of motivation around security and I
actually want to go back to October 21st
2016 and this is a day that many of you
may remember when a lot of these popular
websites Twitter and Amazon and PayPal
were unavailable largely on the eastern
seaboard
but also also on the west coast kind of
all over the US and these sites were
unavailable on and off throughout the
day and this of course lets this kind of
rampant speculation that the United
States was under attacked this was
another nation-state trying to take down
American infrastructure this was right
before the election people were saying
this this is a trial run so we got these
kind of crazy different statements from
everyone and so they actually wanted to
describe what actually happened because
actually kind of interesting so what
happened that day was that there is a
massive denial of service attack against
a large DNS provider called dine dine is
kind of those big plumbing companies on
the internet that provided DNS for
Twitter for Amazon
these other companies allowed you to do
the lookup from domain to what were
these groups IP addresses and they came
under a massive denial of service attack
that day that essentially overload their
network overloaded a lot of their
servers and this was probably the first
time we had seen an event kind of this
this size or of this scale there's
actually the third event in a series of
four that looks very different than the
previous denial of service attacks we
had seen on the internet the first one
actually happened in September of 2016
and it was an attack that hit the
European hosting provider OVH and then
there was another one that hit a blog
for Brian Krebs a security blogger and
researcher later in September and then
in October this first one hit dine and
that's when people really started to
take notice that there was this large
attacks but these kind of four attacks
looked very different from what we had
seen before in these there were kind of
two major differences first was just the
sheer magnitude of the attack this DDoS
attack that we saw against dine that we
saw against Krebs was about twice as
large of an attack that we had ever seen
publicly documented before so the attack
was somewhere between 600 gigabits per
second to a terabyte of traffic coming
in and beforehand we had seen somewhere
around 360 gigabits of traffic in the
second way it was different was that we
had been very used to seeing distributed
denial of service attacks that were
amplified in the past someone would send
essentially spoofed the source IP
address of a client they would send this
to a DNS resolver to an FTP server to
some sort of service that would amplify
the request and they would send that
amplified request to the target victim
and this would mean that even if you
only had one gigabit of bandwidth you
could still deliver quite a punch it
with a 60 or 70 times increase in the
amount of data that you were sending and
this is what we had been seeing for
quite a while in the DDoS space but what
hit these four attacks actually didn't
use any amplification there wasn't this
60 to 70 times increase in the traffic
in fact is all organic traffic it was
direct connections from hosts on the
Internet
that were a sudden get requests I were
sending malformed router packets there
but but it was 600 gigabits of true
traffic coming from devices and what was
also different was that the IP addresses
we had seen in this attack or IP address
we really never seen on the internet
before these were not normal client
addresses in fact there are all IOT
devices they were the smallest devices
on the Internet these were these were
web cameras and cable modems and these
devices that people deploying don't
think about you don't even think to
these even really have a CPU they do it
has some small ARM processor are some
small Intel processor but the sheer
magnitude of the number of these devices
was able to take down and produce a much
larger attack than we had ever seen on
the Internet these devices that were
part of this attack were all infected
with a piece of malware called mer I
just actually want I want to talk about
today and Mariah was kind of the first
major piece of malware that's targeted
IOT devices it's not necessarily the
first both the first that was really
successful that had this magnitude of
attack pulled off the malware itself is
pretty simple
bots once are infected go out and they
perform stateless scanning for other
hosts to infect and in the beginning
this was scanning for telnet they would
search for different any ipv4 address
randomly they had port 23 open and later
on they added the second port 23 23
which we kind of call the IOT telnet
port just because IOT devices thought
they were adding security by by changing
the port slightly and they scan for
these random posts and then they would
attempt to log in with about five to ten
default usernames and passwords and
these were AB minute like passwords like
admin admin a root password these were
not ingenious combinations these were if
you sat down a row 5 or 10 things on a
paper probably what you would write down
so these bots go often they scan they
find other devices to infect
they report them all back to kind of a
central situ or command and control
server that server then says essentially
sends out a task to load malware on the
machine that mount that that loader logs
in it deploys a binary that essentially
takes over the machine it kills some of
the running processes and it starts up
and in it it converts that IOT device
into a bot and then that bot kind of
takes over and starts to do its own
thing it starts to scan it starts to
look for other hosts to infect and it
kind of just sits there and waits so
during this process the bot master is is
collecting BOTS to use it's building its
army and these BOTS all sit there until
they receive a signal that says go off
an attack and we'll talk about a little
later of who they attacked and why but
this looks a lot like the malware we had
seen on desktop computers but it was
very specifically targeted towards IOT
devices so I mentioned this wasn't the
first piece of malware that went at IOT
but it was by far the most successful
and it was almost an accident that this
distance was successful the reason why I
was so successful was that it was so
stupidly simple the authors actually
really made pretty much every error you
can make in a piece of malware there
randomization algorithm actually didn't
have full coverage over the IP space
they messed up the Indian NIST and IP
addresses and blacklisted what they
thought was like the u.s. post office
actually we're actually just taking off
the random last couple of bits of IP
addresses there they're loading service
would drop packets the code didn't
really make sense in the beginning we
were fascinated by this cuz we all
actually thought this was like an
obfuscation kind of tactic we thought
that there was just something we were
missing in this and the answer was no it
was just it was terrible it looked like
code that like a high school student had
cobbled together and and tried to run
but it didn't take more than logging in
was the username of admin and password
to take over these devices in fact the
reason it was so successful was because
it was so simple all they needed was a
shell or bash command and they would run
a couple bass processes but that's what
all of these devices have in common all
of these different devices from
different manufacturers might have had
the username admin and the password
admin but because they didn't try to go
after any vulnerabilities that were
specific to devices they were able just
to kind of take the shotgun approach and
they had no idea what they were gonna
take over I think was probably just as
much a surprise to them as a to us to us
of who they actually were able to infect
but it was the simplicity that really
led to the success in this in this
ecosystem so the author's took these
existing pieces of malware and
essentially dumb them down and added a
little bit more statelessness and they
were able to take over hundreds of
thousands of devices with it so that's
kind of the background of what Mirai was
but what actually happened in October
and I think this was actually a little
bit more interesting and the first
question I think is very simple one how
large was Mirai
how many bops did it actually take over
and the news sources had numbers all
over the place we saw numbers from a
half million to a million to millions
and a lot of those were pretty
exaggerated because a lot of these posts
were in space where there's just a lot
of churn and so a lot of these these
hosts were being double counted but
we're actually able to track pretty
specifically the size of the botnet
because is scanned using this kind of
bizarre hacks together approach that was
actually very finger printable from the
outside they took static values and they
put them in all the fields I should have
been random like your IP ID and your TCP
sequence number and you have several
these fields where you usually have 32
bits of entropy but they just use the
same value in each of them so if you
watched the traffic that you saw coming
into a large network it was pretty
obvious what machines were part of Mirai
we actually saw the first scan on August
1st 2016 there this actually isn't an
IOT device it was a server that was
rented out of a hosting provider in New
Jersey that was like a kind of
bulletproof hosting provider named ate a
wagon and they scan for about two hours
and you can kind of see this the
beginning of what's going on then after
two hours they stop and then we start to
see the botnet emerge so what happened
was this person since you ran a scan
from a host they controlled they found a
list of initial IP addresses to go after
then they went and loaded malware on
them and then they said okay all of my
BOTS go forth and look for more victims
so within the first minute of the botnet
starting there about eight hundred
devices infected this raised to about
eleven thousand in about ten minutes and
then it continues to grow by the end of
the first day about 24 hours there's
about 65,000 hosts that have been
infected and are going out and scanning
and again this is just based on logging
in with default usernames and passwords
I think there's five hard-coded in the
initial malware and we see this kind of
it's it remains small in the beginning
and then we see a couple large jumps the
first big jump you kind of see where the
green up appears is where they started
to also scan for part 23:23 instead of
just pure telnet and then you see
another large jump kind of right at the
beginning of december where they started
scan for protocol CW MP or customer it's
a it's a protocol that lets essentially
ISPs controlled cable modems on their
networks so actually this giant pop like
right here is like three ISPs or so that
just had default usernames and passwords
had vulnerable cable modems in this
space and then you see that the ISP
notices this that all on their entire
ISP doesn't work and it's just scanning
and they patch and then you can kind of
see this decay as as folks restart their
modems that they come back and take on
their normal kind of
activity so at the peak here in December
there's about 600,000 hosts that are
infected but the steady-state kind of
stays somewhere between 200 and 300
thousand hosts then you'll notice coming
towards the end it starts to to decrease
and that's not good news actually I'll
come back to that a little bit later so
mariah takes over 600,000 of these IOT
devices and it's capable of producing
about 600 gigabits of DDoS traffic
taking down these pretty large providers
what did Mariah actually take over we
can actually look at this because most
of these devices that you could login
over telnet also had web interfaces that
actually very helpfully tell you exactly
what they are you might even be the
telnet prompt that says hey you're
logging into a neck your router or
you're logging into this camera but we
can go through and we can pull out using
internet wide scanning what all the
websites and all these devices look like
at the time that they were taken over
and from that we can start to understand
what these actually were and they truly
are
IOT devices we actually see very few
devices that were desktop computers or
anything like that
the vast majority were home routers they
were cameras and DVRs they were NASA's
like network attached storage devices
really they were have all over the place
it was just happen to be where they saw
the passwords that matched up and if you
actually look at the passwords that you
guess some of them are specific enough
that we can track them back to a
specific creator or manufacturers in
other cases when the passwords 1 2 3 4 5
don't really know who they're targeting
that password is used across the number
of manufacturers but you start to see
patterns among the types of devices that
these are going after
so I mentioned the beginning that these
are the four kind of large attacks there
was OVH there's Brian Krebs there was
dying but those are really kind of top
four because I grabbed our attention by
deploying honey pots and actually
watching the commands that came in to
these BOTS we could actually tell who
they were going after and it's kind of
an eclectic list you might be saying to
yourself what do these websites really
have in common you have quite literally
cooking blogs and then you also have
dine who's a major major provider on the
Internet what what what do these all
have in common and the answer is
actually pretty much nothing and the
reason for that is that on September
30th I'm kind of in an underground
hacking forum there is this post where
the author of Merai essentially said
here's the malware everyone go at it and
this wasn't necessarily an act of
[Music]
goodwill on his part it's actually a
fairly known kind of tactic of if you
believe your being that that the police
are starting to find who you are one way
of getting rid of the evidence is giving
it to everyone and so then all sudden
every researcher has it every every
nefarious actor has a copy of this
malware and when this happened Mirai
started to evolve so starting is this
very dumb piece of malware that scanned
five usernames and passwords but the
moment went into the forums people
started to add features and this is
where you seize things like all of a
sudden there's this giant spike of the
CW MP hosts is because one variant
decided they would add one vulnerability
they would start to add to scan for
another type of device that they would
add different if
protocols different passwords different
ranges that they block different tactics
for how they would prevent the device
from being infected in the future it
what was really interesting is we
actually saw essentially the last ten
years of malware evolution occur over
the process of the span of a couple
weeks so we've had this long history of
desktop malware getting smarter and
smarter starting to use domain
generation algorithms starting to remove
other viruses that are on that machine
so that you have full control and we saw
the exact same thing happen once this
was released so we went from this really
dumb piece of malware within a couple of
weeks to essentially a pretty
sophisticated looking piece of malware
and this actually starts to lead into
why we saw this kind of downward slope
but as this happened the other thing
that happened was that you also tuned
now had different factions that were
controlling different parts of the
botnet and they actually started to
fight each other so when you actually
look at who was being attacked what
you'd notice would be that in one of the
clusters they would be attacking the
command and control servers of another
cluster because the idea was if that
that command control server went down
you could take over its bots that they
eventually reboot and try to find a new
master and you would take them over and
so there's this large evolution but in
the end there ended up being a couple of
very large clusters and what I have up
here on the screen essentially is a
clustering of the command and control
infrastructure associated with different
clusters so we go in and we look at all
the DNS names and the IP addresses and
the ownership of these different
resources at ISPs at these DNS providers
and we're able to link these together by
saying these three names point to this
IP address one of them migrated over to
another IP address we can start to piece
together the story but this also starts
to tell a story of why did we see such a
weird range of websites being attacked
so the first cluster that you see this
green one is actually the original one
it's the
went after Brian Krebs is the one that
went over OVH you see cluster 2 which is
looks like the largest which actually is
what we call booter service essentially
the the owners of that pitiable website
and they would say if you give me a
Bitcoin
I will das your enemy and there's
actually this full marketplace you can
go and you can actually bid and say this
is how much Bitcoin or how much other
money I want to spend on this attack and
then you'll say I want to purchase one
hour of DDoS against my my competitors
cooking blog and there's been a large
ecosystem of this in kind of the the
amplification space but we again saw the
same thing emerge here in the in the IOT
space there still isn't necessarily an
obvious question like answer of why
attack both Brian Krebs and dine and ovh
like why why go after these large these
large hosting providers and and why if
you can't put together code do you think
I'm gonna go after one of the largest
DNS providers in the country and the
extra answer is minecraft actually one
of the reasons that these
denial-of-service kind of groups come up
is that there's a lot of money to be
made running a minecraft server and it's
very easy to get folks to move over to
another minecraft server it's not like
you have to move all your infrastructure
from ec2 to Google cloud or something
like that
gamers say this servers down as long as
all of us moved to the same other
provider let's move and so this is being
used was using for blackmail
they were actually extorting the owners
of very large minecraft servers on OVH 4
dime it was actually going after
PlayStation servers deine hosts the
authoritative DNS records for
PlayStation and so while what we see
from the outside looks like an attack
that's going after dying as a whole the
that dine went down was actually just an
unfortunate circumstance these attackers
were really just going after these
PlayStation servers and if you if you
das correctly you can you can you have
an advantage in this game because your
other the other players don't know that
this is coming that can't time their
moves and it had nothing to do with an
attack beyond just going after a couple
of these servers for Brian Krebs um
they were actually just pissed at him
they were really upset that he had
written an article that kind of had
uncovered a similar booter operation and
it was run by their friends and they
decided to go after him for this and
that retribution was the largest attack
we had seen on the Internet but again it
was they were annoyed their friend had
been had been arrested because of an
article that Brian had written like
that's where we are we took down the
large like DNS provider because a couple
of folks are really upset about a blog
post that's where we are in the IOT
space right now so who are these people
um as I mentioned the authors of this
did some really stupid stupid things and
we actually know who did it
they were actually arrested in the end
of 2017 these were a couple of college
students they were undergrads they had
started a business operation where they
would blackmail the owners of these
minecraft servers that was their
business they were wood they would send
some an email saying if you don't move
over to our superior DDoS protection
service your website's gonna go offline
really they just wouldn't das them if if
they paid up
and this just spiraled and others took
control once they have
the malware has started to build on top
of it right how's this somewhat ironic
name or maybe it's depressing I don't
know of the future and I don't know if
this was necessarily know what the
author's meant when they named this this
but it does kind of raise this
interesting question of this likely is
kind of the future unless we start to
clean up this act and it's not just
policy most of these devices actually
we're not in the United States most of
them or actually in shakin I don't have
this slide but I can pull it up there's
this bias here actually you can't see
this can you let's see shows to you most
of these devices were not in the United
States these were in regions that we
didn't really consider having
significant amounts of bandwidth they
were in South America they were in
Southeast Asia and the reason that this
malware looked to kind of tail off at
the end isn't that these devices have
been patched it's actually that the
malware has gotten more sophisticated
that new botnets have taken over and
they are using much harder to detect
methods of taking all the other hosts
they're starting to use attacks that
aren't just usernames and passwords
guessing and we hadn't really seen
attacks from these new mouths these new
pieces of malware from these new botnets
that are taking over from Arai but we do
know that they are slowly ramping up in
size and they are capable of of starting
these attacks that I mean as part of
this Akamai said to Brian Krebs you've
got you have to move off this is
affecting our production network that
there's only a couple providers in the
world that can actually withstand the
attacks that are now possible from these
IOT devices from this this kind of lack
of
tension into the security and it's kind
of rushed to the bottom to get these
devices out and deployed the work
presented here was part of a very large
team across industry across law
enforcement and as well as academic
users to look at the traffic that was
actually seen at dine Siena Akamai seen
at Google to look at the DNS
infrastructure behind these attacks but
there is a paper out there if this is of
interest to other folks to kind of
understand more in depth what was going
on with that I'll take any questions
[Applause]
um so ipv6 to me is 2096 times larger
this is actually a very interesting
academic research question to me is how
do you scan ipv6 how do you understand
these devices it's not possible to just
brute force that's not going to work you
have to have a much more intelligent
kind of plan a more elegant approach
where you look at what devices have been
deployed can you detect what addressing
schemes have been used in different
regions so maybe you look at the
interests DNS records and you see that
these are a certain offset apart between
the IPS they give hosts and from there
you can start to learn and understand
how you should use different regions I
don't think will necessarily get to the
fully comprehensive kind of scan that we
saw for Mirai or we've seen first for
tools like Z map but I do think we will
see a fact of ipv6 solutions actually I
have to ask before this is a question it
must be on people's minds yes is what do
we do to prevent these kind of things to
prevent these um I mean the bar here I
think for IOT is love of many ways from
the security perspective these weren't
genius attacks these were usernames and
passwords and I think the question is
how do we enable these manufacturers to
build secure devices by default how and
this is where I think like we'll work
with talk for examples really
interesting of can we build these
primitives that enable people to be
faster and also to be more secure at the
same time so that they're incentivized
to do the right thing we do in terms
what can we do in terms of internet
architecture and infrastructure to deal
with this is every packet going to need
a passport across an international
border it gets tough when you add that
that international part at the end in
the amplification space there are simple
things to be done a lot of this can be
can be handled by doing egress filtering
correctly in this space
it's not immediately obvious what to do
because these aren't devices that are
sending a lot of bandwidth it's very
hard to detect that this is an attack
when each device has such a small amount
there have been a lot of proposals in
this space but it's unclear right now
what we do that actually works with kind
of how the Internet is currently
deployed and so there's many times be a
reticle ideas out there of ways to solve
this but I haven't seen really tractable
solutions today that we can employ or
similar works to be practical and
relevant to this at all
so I didn't catch the first happier
question so frameworks like vanadium
decentralized authorization you know for
IOT are they practical are they do they
have any promise um there's there's
technical practicality and there's also
kind of this like real world can we get
actually manufacturers to you that use
this and I think that second part is
where this is really tough where how do
we actually convince manufacturers that
they should be taking these steps when
it doesn't allow them to sell more
products or to to to more quickly deploy
products so that's where I really think
we have to have this kind of other side
of this to make jobs easier in order to
kind of sent avise people to use these
technical solutions
okay thank you very much for using
Japanese words us senpai and Mirai okay
every every IOT device should have the
computer that processes a quick
cryptograph what do we think I'm not
sure I understand computer I only
devices should have a computer that
process no yes
very important questions I absolutely
agree that needs to be there thing that
happened was that you also didn't now
had different factions that were
controlling different parts of the
botnet and they actually started to
fight each other um so when you actually
look at who was being attacked what
you'd notice would be that in one of the
clusters they would be attacking the
command and control servers of another
cluster because the idea was of that
that command control server went down
you could take over its bots that they
eventually reboot and try to find a new
master and you would take them over and
so there's this large evolution but in
the end there ended up being a couple of
very large clusters and what I have up
here on the screen essentially is a
clustering of the command and control
infrastructure associated with different
clusters so we go in and we look at all
the DNS names and the IP addresses and
the ownership of these different
resources at ISPs at these DNS providers
and we're able to link these together by
saying these three names point to this
IP address one of them migrated over to
another IP address we can start to piece
together this story but this also starts
to tell a story of why did we see such a
weird range of websites being attacked
so the first cluster that you see this
green one is actually the original one
it's the one that went after Brian Krebs
is the one that went over OVH you see
cluster 2 which is looks like the
largest which actually is what we call
booter sir
this essentially the the owners of that
printable website and they would say if
you give me a Bitcoin
I will das your enemy and there's
actually this full marketplace you can
go in you can actually bid and say this
is how much bitcoin or how much other
money I want to spend on this attack and
then you'll say I want to purchase one
hour of DDoS against my my competitors
cooking blog and there's been a large
ecosystem of this in kind of the the the
amplification space but we again saw the
same thing emerge here in the in the IOT
space there still isn't necessarily an
obvious question like answer of why
attack both Brian Krebs and dine and ovh
like why why go after these large these
large hosting providers and why if you
can't put together code do you think I'm
gonna go after one of the largest dns
providers in the country in the extra
answer is minecraft actually one of the
reasons that these denial of service
kind of groups come up is that there's a
lot of money to be made running a
minecraft server and it's very easy to
get folks to move over to another
minecraft server it's not like you have
to move all your infrastructure from ec2
to Google cloud or something like that
gamers say this servers down as long as
all of us moved to the same other
provider let's move and so this is being
used was using for blackmail they were
actually extorting the owners of very
large minecraft servers on OVH for dying
it was actually going after PlayStation
servers Dyne hosts the authoritative DNS
records for PlayStation and so while
what we see from the outside looks like
an attack that's going after dying as a
whole the fact that Dyne went down was
actually just an unfortunate
circumstance these attackers are really
just going after these PlayStation
servers and if you if you dose correctly
you can you can you have an advantage in
this game because your other the other
players don't know that this is coming
that can't time their moves and it had
nothing to do with an attack beyond just
going after a couple of these servers
for Brian Krebs um
they were actually just pissed at him
they were really upset that he had
written an article that kind of had
uncovered a similar booter operation and
it was run by their friends and they
decided to go after him for this and
that retribution was the largest attack
we had seen on the Internet but again it
was they were annoyed their friend had
been had been arrested because of an
article that Brian had written like
that's where we are we took down the
large like DNS provider because a couple
of folks are really upset about a blog
post that's where we are in the IOT
space right now so who are these people
um as I mentioned the authors of the
this did some really stupid stupid
things and we actually know who did it
they were actually arrested in the end
of 2017 these were a couple of college
students they were undergrads they had
started a business operation where they
would blackmail the owners of these
minecraft servers that was their
business they were with they would send
some an email saying if you don't move
over to our superior DDoS protection
service your website's going to go
offline really they just wouldn't das
them if if they paid up and this just
spiraled and others took control once
they had released the malware and
started to build on top of it
right has this somewhat ironic name or
maybe it's depressing I don't know of
the future and I don't know if this was
necessarily know what the authors meant
when they named this this but it does
kind of raise this interesting question
of this likely is kind of the future
unless we start to clean up this act and
it's not just policy most of these
devices actually were not in the United
States most of them or actually in
shakin I don't have this slide but I can
pull it up there's this bias here
actually you can't see this can you
let's see shows to you most of these
devices were not in the United States
these were in regions that we didn't
really consider having significant
amounts of bandwidth they were in South
America they were in Southeast Asia and
the reason that this malware looked to
kind of tail off at the end isn't that
these devices have been patched it's
actually that the malware has gotten
more sophisticated that new botnets have
taken over and they are using much
harder to detect
methods of taking all the other hosts
they're starting to use attacks that
aren't just usernames and passwords
guessing and we haven't really seen
attacks from these new mouths these new
pieces of malware from these new botnets
that are taken over from Arai but we do
know that they are slowly ramping up in
size and they are capable of of starting
these attacks that I mean as part of
this Akamai's said to Brian Krebs you've
got you have to move off this is
affecting your production network that
there's only a couple providers in the
world that can actually withstand the
attacks that are now possible from these
IOT devices from this this kind of lack
of attention into the security and it's
kind of rushed to the bottom to get
these devices out and deployed
the work presented here was part of a
very large team across industry across
law enforcement and as well as academic
users to look at the traffic that was
actually seen at dine scene at Akamai
seen at Google to look at the DNS
infrastructure behind these attacks but
there is a paper out there if this is of
interest to other folks to kind of
understand more in depth what was going
on with that I'll take any questions
[Applause]
um so ipv6 to me is 2096
times larger this is actually a very
interesting academic research question
to me is how do you scan ipv6 how do you
understand these devices it's not
possible to just brute force that's not
gonna work you have to have a much more
intelligent kind of plan a more elegant
approach where you look at what devices
have been deployed can you detect what
addressing schemes have been used in
different regions so maybe you look at
the indirect DNS records and you see
that these are certain offset apart
between the IPS they give hosts from
there you can start to learn and
understand how you should use different
regions I don't think will necessarily
get to the fully comprehensive kind of
scan that we saw for Mirai or we've seen
first for tools like Z map but I do
think we will see a fact of ipv6
solutions actually I have to ask before
this is a question it must be on
people's minds yes is what do we do to
prevent these kind of things different
these um I mean the bar here I think for
IOT is low in many ways from the
security perspective
these weren't genius attacks these were
usernames and passwords and I think the
question is how do we enable these
manufacturers to build secure devices by
default how and this is where I think
like will work with pop for example is
really interesting of can we build these
primitives that enable people to be
faster and also to be more secure at the
same time so that they're incentivized
to do the right thing we do in terms
what can we do in terms of internet
architecture and infrastructure to deal
with this is every packet going to need
a passport across an international
border it gets tough when you add that
that international part at the end in
the amplification space there are simple
things to be done a lot of this can be
can be handled by doing egress filtering
correctly in this space
it's not immediately obvious what to do
because these aren't devices that are
sending a lot of bandwidth it's very
hard to detect that this is an attack
when each device has such a small amount
there have been a lot of proposals in
this space but it's unclear right now
what we do that actually works with kind
of how the Internet is currently
deployed and so there's many times
theoretical ideas out there of ways to
solve this but I haven't seen really
tractable solutions today that we can
employ or similar works to be practical
and relevant to this at all so I didn't
catch the first happier question so
frameworks like vanadium decentralized
authorization you know for IOT are they
practical are they do they have any
promise um there's there's technical
practicality and there's also kind of
this like real world
can we get actually manufacturers to
Uthoff use this and I think that second
part is where this is really tough where
how do we actually convince
manufacturers that they should be taking
these steps when it doesn't allow them
to sell more products or to to to more
quickly deploy products so that's where
I really think we have to have this kind
of other side of this to make jobs
easier in order to kind of sent avise
people to use these technical solutions
okay thank you very much for using
Japanese was sent by and the Mirai okay
every IOT device should have the
computer that process is a quick
cryptography what do you think I'm not
sure I understand
computer IOT devices should have a
computer that process the yes very
important questions I absolutely agree
that needs to be there I think in in
some ways it's it's a little orthogonal
to this I mean you can have very good
secure communication still be vulnerable
to these types of attacks I think it's
again it's kind of question how do you
bring this all together to really make
it make people want to deploy it time
probably are depending on depending on
computers but the computer should be as
small as right right and I mean that's
what I think that that's coming back to
this is the future is this really is the
start I mean in many ways we say IOT is
pervasive but I think we're really at
just kind of tip of this iceberg and
that's both a pro and a con I I think it
means that we are in kind of a time in
the space where we can kind of mold
where this goes but at the same time
it's very evident that we have to that
we have to come up with effective
solutions or this is going to become a
much larger problem cool all right well
great thanks great excellent questions
Thanks it here
you